all right joining us now with more
reaction Senator Lindsey Graham Senator
you're a lawyer you're a lawmaker I've
never seen anything like this in my life
no it's a systematic effort to destroy
Donald Trump as a political person his
crime was he was a good conservative
president I've never seen hatred toward
a political figure like I see against
President Trump the left will do
anything to ruin his life to keep him
from being president again and here's
the good news if you're a conservative
it's not working he can't be in South
Carolina today but let me tell you the
people in South Carolina are watching
what's happening to him in New York and
we're not going to let New York get away
with this if you think
how do you stop a job he wins the
primary he gets to be president again
this judge is a joke
who got defrauded nobody everybody who's
the
victims Money Paid the insurance
companies got paid and by the way I
should add it says in the contract yeah
don't go by our valuations because they
have a fiduciary responsibility to do
their own fiscal uh valuations you're
not going to take the word of uh
somebody that wants to borrow that kind
of money you have to look at the that's
insane but let's look at the AG she
started attacking president Trump in
2018. and she promised if she got to be
the Attorney General of New York she
would make this guy's life miserable
that she would go after him look under
every Rock so she has used Donald Trump
to elevate herself politically she is
trying to get ahead at Donald Trump's
expense the judge has ruled that
President Trump committed fraud and
nobody got defrauded the judge believes
that miralago's worth 18 billion dollars
what a freaking joke now here's what's
important to people watching this show
president Trump can't be in Iowa in
South Carolina and New Hampshire but if
you live in these states you can help
him by making sure that liberals do not
get away with this vote for president
Trump all right Senator good to talk to
you appreciate you being with us thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else